we're going to jump into this guy right
here phil defranco oh we're going to
talk about philadelphia okay um i should
be a big fan of phil defranco he was his
own guy he uh started on youtube a long
time ago one of the ogs and he built up
this uh this news
company he had source fed and i was
always i was always like man this guy he
works hard he was calm rational
reasonable he interviewed gary johnson
he brought alternate alternative voices
to the political debate and i was like
this is cool it is cool to see that
through youtube we can we can hear more
from people like you know the
libertarian party granted the
libertarian party
little jack sparrowy but uh today i just
see these tweets from him and it's like
he's just become so mean
he was always kind of snarky like that
yeah yeah yeah but it's one thing i i
don't know man maybe maybe i'm just
wrong but
uh i've met him a couple times i've
talked with him and he always seemed to
be
willing to listen and kind of more
reasonable like when the media ecosystem
was was on tv yelling and and and things
like that he always presented the news
in a way that was more so like well
let's take a look at what they're saying
and why like let's be reasonable here's
what he has now
phil defranco tweeted
imagine having the cred the eligibility
access to get the vaccine and saying nah
also to the pearl clutchers offended by
this tweet yes i am calling you stupid
and you can go f yourself you ignorant
selfish f face
he then posted again
f man damn it this isn't me i missed the
mark i would really like to apologize if
you'll give me the time to read this i
saw that tweet when he said that and i
was like that's cool man that's like
phil and then i read what he actually
posted
just kidding hahaha f you again and the
people saying oh wow namekong is really
going to convince me i'm done trying to
convince you that's over i'm just going
to mock you for believing a bunch of
f-face grifters monetizing
misinformation and or ignorance
ignorance over scientists using the most
recent and relevant info
so look
i'm not going to cry about it's like
whatever i don't know you know he does
his thing that's fine but i saw that and
i'm like what happened to us
what what what he wasn't always like
that
no no no he was sexy phil dude if you
know phil in the early days his video
channel was so sexy straight
which is straight edge phil yeah pure
phil being sexy in his bedroom all black
and white chilling mystery guitar man
writes his killer theme song it's phil
he's a normal dude but but even even
six years ago like the last time i saw
him at vidcon or whatever and he was
like hey you know he's really nice
really calm really chill now he's on
twitter just
calling people f-face and insulting them
i was thinking this about sarah
silverman too it seems like i don't know
if it's in
indicative of celebrities only but it
seems like people that are kind of
tertiary on the outskirts watching
what's happening have like a snapping
mental break moment and then it comes
out in some dumb twitter post remember
sarah silverman but look just get over
it people like she just had it yeah this
is phil just having it yes but he's also
he also on the wrong side of the
covington kids thing
it's not it's it's been a gradual thing
where oh phil yeah the dudes like look
man
i'm not i'm i'm not gonna cry that he's
calling people these these things i'm
asking i'm just asking like why is that
happening probably because he doesn't
have anyone around telling him he's an
idiot
i mean his wife's pretty cool but you
look at what happens when these things
happen right now there'll be some drama
they'll be like oh you know tim poole
said x or whatever all i'm saying is why
you got to be so mean to people all the
time why is everyone constantly trying
to be mean i want to be mean to phil i
was i'm
i was i was a big fan until i started
seeing him tweet stuff like this and i'm
just like i don't like people being just
mean directly to other people he's he's
got kids i think he has two kids now so
he's maybe he's being like overly
protective of it and bought into the the
hype and i i also want to say this is
not an excuse to be like a total dick
though also but i also did say what
happened to us i'm not absolving myself
from any of the responsibility for the
things i've said some horrible stuff to
people in the last 20 years and i'm just
wondering like man can we just kind of
look i'm not going to be unfair to
myself i genuinely try to avoid directly
insulting and name calling i do a very
good job but sometimes i'll mock people
and i'll like you know i'll do like you
know really snide impersonations of them
but i genui i generally try to avoid
things like this that are just really
nasty really low really angry and mean
no forgiveness that's like the key thing
here like what happened to being like yo
let's work this out let's be nice to
each other but one thing that is going
on too and we can go back to the i mean
discussing this vaccine passport
situation is that is bullying right
saying to people you can't go to work
you can't work out you can't eat out you
can't participate in life unless you do
this thing that i'm demanding that you
do whatever it is whatever it is that's
a bullying thing to do that's a mean
bully thing to do and so i understand
from the same people who are constantly
saying like oh don't bully we have to
have special sessions in all of our
schools and so here's one here's not to
be bullies here's what i want to point
out when he says i'm going to mock you
for believing a bunch of f-face grifters
monetizing misinformation and or
ignorance over scientists using the most
recent relevant info
you know what that you know the the the
nail in the coffin for me this one for
me on this one is one of the biggest
issues from upmc university of
pittsburgh and carnegie mellon
university researchers and researchers
identified groups hesitant about covet
19 vaccine and they say
hesitancy held constant in the most
educated group those with a phd by may
phds were the most hesitant group while
vaccine hesitancy decreased across
virtually all racial groups they say
blacks pacific islanders had the largest
decrease they mentioned that those with
high school educations or less were the
most likely to reduce their vaccine
hesitancy
so here's my my overall point about
what what phil is doing
not only is he being really really mean
to people but he's oh he is also very
very wrong about what he's talking about
the people who are being misled or you
know whatever are not
mo like
first of all why would you be mean to
somebody who is confused by by lies
like if people when people believe bad
things i don't say you're a stupid [ __ ]
i say that's not true let me show you
the proof
so why come out insult them and it turns
out of all the people he's criticizing
he's criticizing people with phds now i
can't tell you why people with phds are
the most hesitant i have no idea so the
point is are we going to pretend like
people with phds are stupid okay well
isn't that the science in academia we
have a re we have a very serious
conundrum of perspectives here this is
this is this is this is science
we're supposed to trust science right
okay well carnegie mellon university and
university of pittsburgh are saying phds
are the most hesitant group
they're also academics and i want to
know why they feel that way i'm not
going to scream at them insult them and
deride them and i'm also i'm i'm not
trying to be mad at phil either i'm just
hoping people kind of chill out and we
can have real conversations again you
know what we did with charlie kirk and
wash i thought was incredible and
there's a photo of all of us we're all
just standing together and everything
and i'm like look at that man you know
they they come here they meet they laugh
they made points they don't agree with
each other at all but at least we can
have something where we can sit down and
be cordial twitter is a nightmare we
should we should just you know what i'm
for one regulation right now ban twitter
just going getting a text communicating
in text that's where all this this dumb
miscommunication is seems to be stemming
but where's the anger coming from dude
from like the lack of emotional
interaction like when it's all taxed
when i etch something on a wall and then
you walk in and look at the wall we're
not having that emotional connection
and so i can see where the anger works i
build i write tweets all the time dumb
thing i'll write a tweet and then i'll
delete it yeah i do that today i do it
like seven times a day i'm like here's
how i feel and i need to share that yeah
you got it too i kind of should have
done that the other day
why what did you tweet
i tweeted about how new york city's
vaccine passports are a total disaster
and i'm definitely going to leave new
york
i still have not people are like oh
let me have your apartment and i'm like
girl the joke's on you yeah that was uh
that was uh dana schwartz it was a
couple of people so there was um but no
it doesn't get good light and it's not a
neighborhood you want to live what
neighborhood well so you're not going to
say
you posted a tweet saying the vaccine
passports were wrong
and then it actually made it to the
front page of reddit
all right the funniest thing about it
was the comments were all calling you an
anti-vaxxer right
and it's like you're you're vaccinating
yeah i'm vaccinated and but see that's
the thing yeah this is the tribalism the
point is that the point is that that's
my choice nobody should have to show
their medical status in order to move
freely about society it's insanity and
their id and their ideas show your
papers we always
we should have a right to live
anonymously in our cities for god's sake
well it's not only that it's that how
how many times have we heard showing
your papers was the wrong thing that we
should never have the authority
demanding papers from people going about
their business you have to watch saying
anything about that too i mean you have
marjorie taylor green comparing you know
vaccine passports and mandates and
things like that to
uh third reich
things and she gets totally slammed for
it so i mean you can't
there's also this there's also this
thing where you can't make comparisons
to historical realities
this is whether that's right whether
it's right or wrong this is the perfect
example of tribalism the fact that when
they see your post saying like we
shouldn't mandate this stuff the
response is anti-vaxxers are so dumb
even though you are vaccinated it shows
that they don't care about reality it's
the other
you know what i just watched the other
day have you guys seen electric dreams
no it's on amazon it's a philip k dick
yeah shorts or whatever
do uh dude you guys got to watch the
10th the final episode i think it's
episode 10 might be episode 8 i don't
know
it is about this guy and it's like it's
like in the near future i guess and
there's one candidate left in the race
and so you vote to affirm that the
president and then this this so this is
a female candidate and she's being
interviewed and she abruptly says kill
all others
and then changes the subject to
education real quickly and then the
interviewer is like i can't believe you
would say something like like that about
education and then this guy's like wait
what
she just said kill all others why isn't
anybody talking about this and he gets
his wife and she's like what are you
talking about i don't care he goes to
work and he's telling all his friends
and they're like man who cares about
politics right then a few days later
there's a billboard that says kill all
others and there's a a person hanging
from a noose and then they're like it's
just politics man it's a it's a gimmick
it's a dummy and so this guy keeps
coming out and saying like why are you
doing this why are you advocating for
this and the people go what are you an
other why are you defending them he's an
other and that's how you identify
yourself it was a brilliant episode and
the gist of it is basically the
authority makes a declaration if you
oppose them you are the person they're
talking you're the problem and that's
what's happening now
if the government says we're going to do
something abusive and authoritarian and
you say i don't think you should do that
they say then you're the nazi you're the
fastest you're the anti-vaccine you're
the problem yep yeah that's it's risky
when you're dealing with totalitarian
regimes because if you come out against
them you'll get murdered but if you
create an
alternate path
that often can work
it is it is extremely
creepy to me what's happening with
everything
about how
you you quite literally have people who
last year were were vaccine or
anti-vaxxers and we all called them
anti-vaxxers hilarious right now like
those people who wouldn't get their kids
vaccinated for against like the measles
and so we had like a measles outbreak in
california i'm talking about last year
when they were all of these blue checks
were ragging on fda in the cdc and near
the big pharma you mean like when kamala
harris was like i wouldn't trump trust a
trump vaccine and cuomo and then all
these other personalities can i tell you
something so we wrote about that uh the
kamala harris vaccine thing um we wrote
like a little we wrote about at the time
kamala harris as opposed to the trump
vaccine you know or whatever it was some
headline and then recently we wrote
about it again we were like let's just
remind people that she said she wouldn't
trust a vaccine you know from the we
were fact-checked for that and it was
like
she's this is what she said the the
article was this is the thing she said
right do you guys remember this is the
thing she said that's all it was it was
like it was like a picture it was like a
blip it was like 200 words it was
nothing it was like a
um i think it was
was it f science feedback maybe it might
have been science feedback but also the
thing do you remember in the spring
dr senator
uh rand paul was talking to fauci and
they did like two segments there was
like a march segment and then a little
later and similar questions so we wrote
a story about like this is what he said
in march this is this was their
conversation in march this was their
conversation in may we got fact check
for that for for not enough context we
literally wrote down the things the
senator said
to the doctor we wrote those things down
did you see that facebook that was
missing context it was literally the
conversation facebook labeled the cdc
fake news no no
there was a cdc article saying that they
were recommending a change in the pcr
test to do like a better test
and then because of a fact checker
label like i guess what people were
saying was like ah this means the test
didn't work and then the fact that
fact checker responded to that link
saying that's not true it did work it's
just a change in methodology but it
automatically applied the fake news tag
to all of the posts that post from the
cdc amazing
because social media knows better they
know what the narrative is and anything
that diverts from the narrative
is false
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time